thank you  Reggie they say the stars come out in  L.A for sure they have tonight  [Music]  [Applause]  Tatum's got it  [Applause]  against James  [Applause]  tayden  that is straight butter and a final shot  from LeBron  going  going with the win  overtime overtime in Los Angeles at 110  for an extra period  with a great game-tying shot right there  to win the vicinity of Westbrook Tatum  rides on Reed step back and thick red  truck  Tatum puts it in  this overtime over four you can see  right there from three for the Lakers  and two-ish up and overall three Brown  bullseye  Right Between the Eyes a terrific come  from behind win on the last game of the  16 road trip and the best team in the  NBA survives and will go home with the  wind ending a two-game losing streak and  going to 22-7